sticking in the legal in the legal space
I want to talk about uh something that
has been tough for it's I want to talk
about something
um
we our podcast was defrauded we were
stolen from
um we were taking advantage of a lot of
ways to say it uh the company that did
it is cast media
and the man that did it is Colin
Thompson and I'm going to put his
picture in here
um and
uh it's
I don't know exactly how to say this I'm
gonna do my best
um we're part of a larger group of
podcasts that were uh stolen from
right we were part the in total I've
just between talking with folks there's
up to four million dollars that I know
of that people were taken advantage of
we're in the six figures I know of
podcasts are in the seven figures
um
and Colin Thompson that's his name I
want to say his name so you know it uh
people get taken advantage of a lot in
business and and and businesses use
tactics and stuff to hide to hide
themselves and uh you know they'll use
bankruptcy or the threat of this or that
and and um
and and he may get my money
that's okay you know I'm fortunate that
I can still have touring and then I uh
can take care of myself but you [__]
with the wrong rat Colin I'll tell you
that brother and uh
and I'll just tell you guys what
happened
um we had a deal with this company right
and and it was started off good and then
it started to get where we were getting
less of our payments
and we were reading the ads we do the
ads you know we read them out loud and
we and and you guys support some of them
and thank you
um
and then it got to be where we were
getting paid less of the payment we were
owed
and they sell all the ads a year in
advance so you're kind of stuck into the
year right
and the advertisers were paying Colin
Thompson and cast media and they weren't
paying us they would pay us a little bit
and they had a reason why and
so one of the craziest Parts was like
there was like we kept asking you know
hey we have to get paid man we have to
and we weren't getting paid and so
finally I was able to make a new deal
um and just cut ties completely I made
sure that everything you know they
breached our contract and so I was able
to cut ties and then they come along
Colin Thompson comes along and he joined
there's a new company that has a stock
that's going live soon right or it's
coming out or something this company
called podcast one or live one right
I he they they get me on a call uh with
I think the guy's name Rob Ellen yeah
that's a guy's name Rob Ellen
um
and his brother is Doug Ellen who's like
a screenwriter and I think he did his
brother was pretty successful
um but they get me on a call with this
guy Rob Ellen right and
and they tell me
um
they tell me that if you come over to
our new network
over to this new network podcast one
that will pay you in some of what you're
owed in stock
right
but the stock hasn't gone public so
they're trying it it felt like to me
they're trying to Leverage
our podcast and other podcasts
to then make their stock do well
um
and then if that happens then we'll get
a share of our money right like
it just the whole thing to me felt
really uh seedy and the worst part to me
was
I said well
what about Colin Thompson
I said that guy's a crook
and they said he's gonna be
um he'll be
they said we felt like he's done a good
job and that he would be part of the
team still
so how that's just
I know some of this is a lot of Insider
baseball man but to me it was just
[__] just it felt real dirty
and it felt like
um
just no respect for podcasting no
respect for the work that we had done
um
you know to get paid by the advertisers
and then not pay us and then uh for
Colin to lead us in this direction and
say well if you join this other group
before their stock goes out that uh
that then will pay you in some of the
stock but part of that will be based on
if we're there for it to do well
I don't I don't know man but I know what
it feels like to be taken advantage of
uh and I wouldn't do that to these
people I wouldn't do that to Colin
Thompson I wouldn't do that to cast
media and um and so I say this just
because I don't want this guy taking
advantage of anybody else
a lot of times in business practices
especially in like um
entertainment stuff A lot of people are
able to snake away
and they're able to slip through and use
tactics and uh shell games and [__]
um but you [__] with the wrong rat
homie I have a voice
and a lot of other people are forced
into these bad deals because they don't
they're afraid to speak up
they're afraid to speak up man and uh
that's not what our show is about and
um
yeah
I just want you guys to know that this
is the man
we put his picture up on the thing on
the YouTube
and the amount of money that I from from
other people podcasters they've said is
over four million dollars
um
and um
yeah it's just this shit's [__] wrong
and I don't also understand how a
company expects me to come wanted me to
come over there
to boot what felt like to me they were
using me to boost their stock price and
I don't say that out of ego but we've
done well
and that they get all these podcasts
saying well that'll boost our stock
price then we'll go public with the
stock and then based again on their
backs
the stock there'll be there will be
money there so it's like it felt like
y'all gonna try to [__] me twice homie
well
no no thank you uh so yeah you can keep
that money
um you can't keep it we'll see how it
plays out but if you do end up keeping
it man
you must have needed it
you must have needed it I don't know I
mean it doesn't make me stoked but
um
but you can't get me to shut up man
you can't get me to shut up
and uh if that's the cost of it for me
to say my [__] piece
you know how many other podcasters
wanted to say this [__] right now but
can't say it
[Music]
so
anyway
um
yeah that's who I just want you to know
I want you to know about Colin Thompson
I want you to know where I've heard he's
going to be working at and I want you to
know that he's a crook and to me it's
criminal
um but it the the way that people are
able to cheat and lie and manipulate the
system
um
you know he went and got Neil sacker who
worked with Harvey Weinstein to jump on
the calls I mean he just
I don't
[__] it's just [__] kind of sad man
and
yeah but I just wanted to speak up for
myself man I've waited a year to speak
up for myself you know he he they put us
through so much [__] and I don't
know if there's other people over there
that did it too and maybe we'll get more
information I don't know or this may be
all you ever hear about it you know
um and so I didn't really know how to
the best way to do this but
um yeah I wouldn't do that to somebody
I mean some of these people's podcast is
all they had man
and these [__] did that bro so
I'm sorry about that
um and I'm sorry for them and yeah I'm
just happy to have a voice for myself
and that's one thing that we built here
that that he had nothing to do with he
had nothing to do with in fact he stole
on our backs once and I'm not letting
these people do it to me two times So
for anybody that had to take that that
sucker deal over there uh this voice I'm
speaking about uh for all of us man
um because I know that some of you guys
have said to me that you wanted to say
some of these same things and
I don't mean that out of ego I just mean
that um I don't know I feel
uh
uh you know I don't know sorry maybe I
shouldn't have said that part I don't
want to speak on behalf of those people
but
um yeah
I just wouldn't have done that to
somebody and uh I'm happy to be able to
speak for myself
I'm so thankful I'm thankful to you guys
to the listeners that we have this place
here
um
and that this is what we try to do and
I'm sorry I've been making this about me
this past five or six minutes or
whatever but
um
um but uh this was the only public place
I could do this where I feel like it
would have some effect because to me
this guy's like the Bernie Madoff of
podcasting and uh
and that almost glorifies him in a weird
way but um I wanted to be able to say
that sorry I'm just rambling but uh I
wanted to be able to speak my peace
thank you